[Musique]
qui connaît ici la permaculture où on
entendu parler oui qui pensent que la
permaculture c'est uniquement une
technique d'agriculture hockey nickel
alors la permaculture dans sa définition
dans une des définitions c'est rétablir
des écosystèmes pour permettre à la
terre de s'autogérer et à l'homme
d'avoir un impact minimum en gros c'est
le jardin du feignants on réfléchit
énormément avant on installe énormément
avant et après on laisse faire la nature
et non sous sous la marque et on attend
que ça arrive je suis pas encore mais la
permaculture s'est pas uniquement
l'agriculture c'est et c'est pour ça
qu'on l'a vu dans les autres
interventions c'est un mode de vie une
philosophie de vie
quand on parlait de l'appareil photo est
de ralentir de vivre l'instant présent
pour prendre des meilleures photos c'est
le principe aussi de la permaculture
revenir à un état naturel observer la
nature
on va passer à la permaculture technique
l'agriculture la première chose à
comprendre c'est que ces systémique
on démarre d'une
d'un endroit et ensuite on observe ce
qui se passe 90% du temps on observe on
met énormément de temps à observer quand
j'ai commencé à me dire que j'allais
mettre en permaculture c'était il ya dix
ans on m'a traitée de folle et on m'a
dit que l'agriculture c'est un métier
très compliqué très fatigant qu'il
fallait utiliser beaucoup de pesticides
et j'aurais dit non je veux m'installer
justement dans un système qui n'utilise
pas de pesticides
donc là j'étais ridicule parce que ça
allait pas marché s'était pas rentable
il ya cinq ans le les moeurs avait un
peu changé quand j'ai commencé à
m'installer vraiment on m'a dit tu vas
pas y arriver mais c'est un beau projet
aujourd'hui comme je me suis installé
vraiment quand quand je me suis ouvert
l'année dernière
les gens sont arrivés en me disant
j'adore la permaculture est ce que vous
faites des formations je veux m'y mettre
en dix ans le changement des moeurs a
été vraiment phénoménal
la permaculture s'est pas uniquement
l'agriculture c'est tous les domaines
dans le domaine de la santé
on retrouve des écosystèmes la médecine
traditionnelle
elle va regarder le corps comme une
mécanique on a un problème à la tête on
nous donne un cachet pour la tête on
cherche pas la cause du mal dans les
médecines alternatives on prend le corps
comme un être organique qu'à des
énergies qui passe on va chercher à
soigner la cause du mal donc on le
regarde dans son ensemble parce que le
corps est un écosystème on retrouve ça
forcément on retrouve ça dans un jardin
on retrouve ça dans l'habitat dans
l'habitat on va chercher à construire
des maisons dites passives
le but est de
d'utiliser le moins d'énergie possible
et si c'est pas pour la planète c'est
cool au moins deux pour le portefeuille
pour payer les factures à la fin du mois
on le retrouve dans l'éducation
et là je pense à au théâtre aussi la
permaculture ça fait ça peut faire
passer des messages
l'éducation alternative comme les écoles
montessori elle nous montre qu' on peut
avoir une autre éducation on peut
montrer aux enfants que la compétitivité
c'est pas un but en soi on peut montrer
aux enfants qu'on n'est pas obligé de se
marcher dessus pour réussir on peut leur
montrer que permaculture c'est aussi de
l'entr'aide la solidarité un exemple
tout bête
il ya trois mois je j'ai découvert une
hernie cervicale
mon bras ne marche pas bien et tout ce
que je devais faire de on va dire de
plus gros en travaux je peux plus le
faire
j'avais le choix entre faire un crédit
et payer des personnes qui puisse me le
faire se peut pas embaucher de gens
encore et demander de l'aide à des amis
qui puisse ou non d'autres personnes qui
puissent venir me le faire et puis
échangé autre chose avec le des légumes
des oeufs
j'ai pas eu besoin demandez dead
ils sont tous venus et
immo aider ils continuent à m'aider
d'une façon ou d'une autre chacun dans
leur dans leur domaine c'est cette
mentalité là qu'on essaye de rétablir un
petit peu en permaculture c'est on n'est
pas dans un échange monétaire on est
dans un échanges relationnels
on peut s'entraider on y perd rien en
fait je peux donner un panier de légumes
contre quelqu'un qui va passer une heure
à passer un motoculteur ou un tracteur
pour des compactes est une terre on
regarde pas la valeur de les changes est
juste les changes relationnel il faut
aussi se rendre compte qu'on est dans un
changement climatique sociales et des
ordres sociaux sont de plus en plus
important on est dépassé par par les
problèmes souvent on se met dans un une
sorte de déni puisqu'on peut rien y
faire puisqu'on est impuissant vaut
mieux ne pas en parler vaut mieux pas
regarder et ça passera peut-être tout
seul ou de toute façon tous les
désordres qui a fini sous jour par
retomber on le voit bien à la télé après
on parle d'autre chose et célébrités
mais les changements sont bien repris
dans l'agriculture on le voit
définitivement on est obligé de
s'adapter on peut faire des choses mais
il faut arrêter d'attendre que les
pouvoirs publics que d'autres personnes
le fasse à notre place et ça dans toutes
lés dans toutes les interventions
aujourd'hui on l'a vu il faut devenir
acteur et arrêtez arrêtez d'être
spectateur devenir actif de sa propre
vie et choisir un engagement quel qu'il
soit moi je parle de la permaculture
parce que c'est ma sensibilité j'ai été
élevé comme ça par mon grand-père il me
disait souvent existé est un fait et
vivre est un art on peut continuer
d'exister on peut avoir un métier qu'on
aime pas forcément mais qui paye 2
le loyer avoir eu une famille se
débrouiller comme ça on est contente et
on n'est pas satisfait personnellement
et on peut prendre un petit risque et
sortir un petit peu de la norme se faire
mal voir souvent le principe de dire
qu'est ce que tu fais comme travail j'ai
tenté une fois bas je fais mon jardin
pas forcément bien passé ils n'ont pas
tout compris on est identifié par notre
travail
mais si on est vraiment identifié que
par notre travail est ce qu'on est
obligé de faire un travail qu'on n'aime
pas ou alors de faire un travail un
métier qu'on aime pour lequel on a été
formé mais le faire mal dans un dans un
système qui s'effondre complètement
nouveau dans l'éducation on le voit dans
la médecine
on n'a plus les moyens de faire notre
métier comment comme on voudrait le
faire surtout dans l'agriculture aussi
est-ce qu'on est obligé de continuer
dans ce système où est ce qu'on peut
trouver des alternatives s'engager avec
une association avoir une idée qui
paraît stupide est tout petit mais
comment ces petits prendre ses voisins
son quartier son arrondissement sa ville
et voir grand parce que des fois ça va
très très vite
on a l'impression qu'on est tout seul on
al'impression nos idées elles sont très
très marginale et qu'on va nous regarder
vraiment d'un mauvais oeil
mais ça tourne très très vite moi je
suis resté seul et je repense à j'ai dit
quand elle disait là quand elle est
arrivée en france la barrière de la
langue où elle se sentait seul j'étais
mal dans ma peau
depuis mes 14 ans je n'ai jamais trouvé
une catégorie de personnes ou un endroit
dans la société j'ai fait des études de
droit
je me sentais pas à l'aise j'ai bossé
j'avais des bons collègues je me sentais
pas à l'aise
le seul endroit où je me sens à l'aise
c'est dans mon jardin et là je peux
accueillir toutes les personnes que je
veux je suis bien je sais que c'est ça
que je veux faire et je sais que je peux
le faire correctement
et à la fin de la journée je suis
fatigué mais j'ai ce sentiment d'avoir
créé quelque chose
on peut ou pas mais franchement si on
doit continuer à vivre des périodes
difficiles
autant essayer de se faire plaisir un
petit peu pour finir deux personnes qui
en a pris en a beaucoup des personnes
qui sont importantes mais ya deux
personnes que je trouve importantes
stéphane hessel qui était résistant lors
de la séquence seconde guerre mondiale
ne disait engagez-vous et indignez vous
je parle pas de la violence ou des
manifestations qui ont tourné violentes
ces derniers temps mais on a le droit de
s'indigner quand dans notre société
certaines de nos lois sont injustes ou
rendre les choses injustes en une
fracture sociale qui énorme
le procès continue à s'agrandir on a le
droit de s'indigner et on peut s'engager
principe de la désobéissance civile pour
ceux qui connaissent une façon ou d'une
autre il ya plein de façons d'être
désobéissance civile s'en aller en
prison après la dernière citation qui
est quand même relativement importante
c'est henry david thoreau qui dit
personne ne peut je paraphrase je suis
pas bonne pour les citations
personne ne peut tout faire mais tout le
monde doit accomplir quelque chose dont
merci
[Applaudissements]